welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the world's
biggest mario golf fan so naturally I'm
very excited for the Last of Us - I'm
just kidding anyway this is a video that
I've been going back and forth on doing
for a while now I've had people tell me
not to do it I've seen youtubers that
I'm a big fan of have their videos
removed but the important thing to take
from this is that I'm an idiot
so yeah I'm covering it I know this
channel isn't really that much of a
gaming one but this story is too big not
to talk about I've had to think about
how to talk about this as well without
being flagged and yeah it's just a weird
weird situation I did report on some
Halloween kills leaks last month and
Universal had it blocked and in the end
it just led to a waste of time and my
channel being in trouble so up top I
will say that in this video I will not
be talking about the leaks themselves or
showing any of the footage this is just
more my reaction to the leaks however
there may still be some spoilers in this
because of the way we talk about things
and if you don't want it ruined then you
need to go play golf or something I'm
sorry that was but anyway make sure you
subscribe the channel because we do
videos that are gonna be a lot better
than this one and yeah you'll like it
here I promise anyway I've sort of been
talking to a great youtuber named Jimmy
champagne about this entire situation
for the best bar of a week now and it's
been good having some someone to just go
back and forth with definitely check out
this channel for great videos too but I
think the best place to start is to talk
about my love for The Last of Us because
it kind of sets up everything in general
so the Last of Us was a game that I got
day one and I came at a time in my life
where I was at university and working a
part-time job so I had a lot of free
time to put into things I played it from
beginning to end it I got it I was
completely blown away by it just
everything about it felt perfect and I
remember feeling shaken by the end of it
it to me was a masterpiece
that almost transcended being a game and
it was it was just a phenomenal story I
don't know why but
sort of felt the same way at the end of
it as I did watching the ending of The
Godfather for the first time and this
game similar that movie ended with
characters knowing that something was a
lie but we also knew that in a way the
characters just had to accept it gives
me goosebumps just talking about it and
honestly it was one of the best
experiences I've had in gaming now I
will say the Last of Us did not need a
sequel it was perfect but when it got
announced I as I'm sure many of you were
excited and I'm actually also sure that
a lot of you watching this video went
through a similar experience to me when
I heard the game had leaked I didn't
want to ruin it for myself
I of course saw the tirade of people
bashing it and saying it was garbage but
I just thought how bad can it be
so I avoided it completely until one day
I saw that the game had a new release
date and I clicked on this tweet and
then saw a post that was about one of
the plot points it sounded ridiculous
and I thought no that can't be true but
then I saw the likes and comments on it
and those saying that it was true and
and thought no way and this kind of sent
me tumbling down the rabbit hole and I
ended up looking up the leaks and seeing
the clips and it just really left me
feeling I don't want to say empty but
like damn they ruined it badly now we
kind of got a whiff of the way that
things were going at Naughty Dog a
couple of years ago with uncharted 4 Amy
Hennig was heading up the project and
she's a phenomenal phenomenal writer
there were rumors that Hennig was pushed
out the company by Neil druckmann
because she refused to put certain
things in the plot of that game and then
there were also reports that a focus
tester was fired from Naughty Dog for
giving feedback I just thought that was
a load of crap because focus testers are
there to give feedback but I think this
report is true and apparently druckmann
was angry that he said he didn't want to
play a strikes daughter which annoyed
d-man and he got rid of them so yeah
already things were starting to look a
bit strange but you know it's the Last
of Us - it's gonna be great it's gonna
be amazing so then more comments came
out by Druckman
Anita sarkeesian if you don't know who
she is she basically runs a YouTube
channel called feminist frequency and at
the time you know a couple of years ago
she was labeled as the savior of video
games someone who would point out all of
the sexism and misogyny that existed
within the medium someone who would save
us all she gained popularity quite
quickly but since then she's kind of
lost her audience because it was clear
after a while that she was just pointing
out non-existent problems and in order
to get attention like some of the videos
that I've seen her post recently are
things like birds of prey is a fun movie
you just hate women and the industry has
silently sort of distanced themselves
away from her however she made Druckman
change his way of thinking and there's a
couple of interviews where he says that
she helped him realize that he was
making misogynist games and I'm sure
she's gonna go out with you now bro so
The Last of Us 2 goes in the development
and this was around about the time that
Hollywood started putting films into
production in which they put agendas
before plot now we know that this has
caused a lot of movies to bomb in the
past couple of years and it looks like
studios are starting to wise up and move
away from this way of thinking because
it just doesn't seem to work it's
probably right because people are sick
of being told that they hate women if
they don't like the movie anyway games
take much longer to make the movies do
on the whole so druckmann encode didn't
have this hindsight troy baker came out
at e3 and said that the Last of Us part
two would have an ending that you need
to have an open mind for a bit of a
warning sign there we then got reports
that they made the female characters
less feminine to appear to be more
inclusive and there were examples of
this where they decreased a character's
breast size to make a more
natural-looking which imagine saying
that a game character looks more natural
looking than a real person anyway
headlines and reports like this are
often written for cliques as I'm sure
you know and I don't tend to pay that
much mind the Get Well Cobra movement
can kind of be annoying and over the top
sometimes and I just thought there's
there's no way this game can be bad
because it's Naughty Dog we then heard
that the game would be about Elly
hunting down home of
big Christian villains and Druckman came
out and said if you're a fob and issed
all believe in something with an ism
then I don't want you to buy our game
now I don't know why but people have
started saying stuff like this a lot
recently and it just seems like virtue
signaling that puts people off who
aren't even those words Tim Miller made
a similar comment with terminator dark
fate and I know that most people aren't
that but if you like me then you see
people spouting things off and just
think well well I don't want anything to
do with this because this guy sounds
like he has a high opinion of himself
and I can't be bothered sitting through
a movie where I'm gonna be lectured to I
don't believe that these things bomb
because people are any of those bad
things and I just think personally that
we're sick of being pounded too now the
Christian villains were the things that
I thought people were kicking off about
like either that or the Elliot and Dinah
kiss and I thought that the controversy
surrounding the game maybe around that
le was clearly always a gay character
though so I didn't get the fuss and I
pre-ordered the game even after I saw
reports that employees had lost their
jobs of a voice and concerns about the
story then the game got delayed
indefinitely and I kind of have a theory
over this I think that Sony saw that it
was gonna be a car wreck and they just
decided to push it back you don't delay
something indefinitely refund people and
then announced its new release day a
couple of days after leaks come out to
me it was clearly ready to be put out
and they decided that things were gonna
be bad so they thought you know what
we'll just delay this and try and fix it
mocap performances were still taking
place in January and I think it's kind
of obvious people were working a way to
change things 70% of the staff of the
department walked out around that time -
and crunch was put in place now this is
a common practice within the industry I
can kind of see both sides of it as
everyone has busy periods in their job
where you're expected to work more
however crunch shouldn't become the norm
and that's what it sounds like it was at
Naughty Dog we were told that leakers
were disgruntled employees that were
fired after asking for bonuses that they
were promised sony then stated that this
wasn't true and that Naughty Dog had
been
I'm not sure if I believe this because
they have covered up being hacked before
I remember the big PSN store wagging and
if it's true it just shows that their
security is lacking it's a bad luck
either way but as this story is still
developing I don't want to say which one
is true when we'll probably never know
unfortunately now Phil it leaks
themselves I have to say I was so
disappointed after reading them that I
didn't believe that they were true
however after seeing the footage it
seems like they are as it all lines up
and clearly the way that Sony was
striking channels adds legitimacy to
them now I will say that it's wrong to
strike channels reporting on leaks
especially ones that don't even show the
footage the hacking if that's what
happened is being labeled as corporate
sabotage but you don't stop something
illegal by also doing something illegal
it's wrong and Sony and Naughty Dog are
wrong for doing it
that being said man you guys messed up
so so much we didn't need a sequel right
you had amazing characters no scratch
that you had some of the best characters
in gaming and he could have just let
them have their ending but you brought
them back for what for this just to
shove a message in our face nah you
messed up and you deserve the backlash
that you're getting now I'm just kind of
sick of this happening to characters I
care about like John Cornell was a
perfect example where you had an amazing
character an amazing franchise and
killed him off just to replace him with
some crappy social message that no one
cares about
good job Naughty Dog you murdered your
best property just to make a point
slow clap golf golf clap now the new
character a B there are rumors that
she's trans and I don't want to get into
that as we don't know if it's true or
not some places are reporting it as
being a fact others aand and you know
either way it doesn't really bother me
so I will say that up top what does
bother me though is that you killed off
some of my favorite characters ever just
to make me play as this person after
watching what she does in the game we
like kill one of the main characters and
then kill a pregnant woman how am I
meant to feel good about playing as that
person like at what stage does that
become something I want to do you guys
made crash bandicoot and now you're
making games where the player is forced
to be someone that murdered a character
we love and a pregnant woman it's
baffling how you drop the ball now
they're pushing the message that this is
actually a really progressive move and
that times are up for old white men that
do what they want but how is it
progressive to have your new characters
mission to be to kill a lesbian couple
whatever her gender is I don't care
Sonic the Hedgehog could show up in the
game and kill the characters that they
do and a pregnant woman and I'd still be
like eff this blue little D head he
killed them like for what for what to
show that violence is cyclical it's a
message that we've seen a ton of times
and it's not is it's not clever it's
just annoying there's even a character
that spits on the character that gets
murdered that looks like Neil druckmann
and he's literally spitting on the
legacy that so many people gave blood
sweat and tears over to create it really
annoys me and I hate this thing where
people think they can just come in kill
off characters and then replace them
with their own political message
terminate and a dog fight again did this
and it completely sucked I don't want
you to crap on the things I'm a fan of
just to pander to people I don't even
know why the people who own these
franchises are giving you the time of
day when your sole purpose is to
literally spit on them this gets in the
way of why we play games and watch
movies I'm not doing this to be told I'm
a bad person for not liking your story
when all your story is focused on is
telling me that I'm a bad person and the
way that you tell that story is kill
characters that I love now clearly the
Last of Us team didn't have the
hindsight that we do now where we know
these tactics just lead to failure so I
think it was too late to change and then
when the leaks came Sony just thought
that they should put it out and deal
with the consequences after reading
these leaks I don't feel bad about
killing those scientists and now the
original
sort of just feels like a big waste of
time to me this is a huge swing and a
miss pun intended and after seeing the
footage I was just so flabbergasted by
it that I didn't want to believe it was
true however I've seen clips that
confirm them and I just don't know what
they were thinking I'm glad I found out
in advance because if this had have
happened when I was playing it I would
have turned off the game and used it as
a frisbee like I think we all know deep
down that the character that dies was
gonna die like they needed their
comeuppance but not like this and even
if you had to had to had to handle it
this badly don't then switch characters
like Ellie was awesome in the first game
and I wouldn't have minded coming back
to play as her just to get revenge that
would have made me want to play the game
just to get the person but to do what
they did and not even let you get
revenge for your friend it's just so
stupid we wanted this game to be zombies
horror not human versus humans that
that's been done to death and you've
ruined your franchise to the point that
you can't even reckon it gender
sexuality and so on aand personality
traits so don't kill someone off who has
a fully developed character just a
shoehorn your stupid message in what the
devil's wrong we're a kind of thing that
this will hear the HBO series 2 as they
recently cancelled the game of Thrones
prequels for being too woke and this
isn't going down well already so I don't
see how people will be hyped for a show
on it now now I will say that I am still
forgetting the game purely for the
channel if it wasn't being covered I
would just wait till the reviews were
out and then when it was on sale because
what a way to ruin this they've isolated
their audience to pander flagged and
reported multiple channels that were
advertising their game for free and
talking about it and everything it's
just such a risk and it rarely pays off
I almost feel like the people who leaked
this are the real sjw's because they
saved the world so much money it just
sucks this had to happen I get the
message you know I get the cyclical
violence message and everything but you
could have done that with Joel and Ellie
and who is getting steroids in the
apocalypse
now I have seen some people saying that
they actually like the leaks and think
they're good and I'm not someone who
thinks they're always right you know the
game could still be great um so yeah
leave your comments below if you
disagree with me I can see how it might
be fun for people who like big twists
and nothing being held back but for me
reading them it's just a big Mis now if
you agree with me then let me know and
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to keep up to date with the story
obviously there's gonna be a lot of
things coming out and at the very least
I will be reporting on the game after
I've had a chance to play through it and
you know see if the plot is really that
bad or if they've added some things in
the end and they've saved it a bit if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in description below those are the
best ways to go today with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]